[Music]
foreign
nothing is more active than thought for
it travels over the universe and nothing
is stronger than necessity for all must
submit to it
[Music]
nothing exists except atoms and empty
space everything else is just opinion
[Music]
it is hard to contend against one's
heart's desire for whatever it wishes to
have it buys at the cost of the Soul
medicine to produce Health must examine
disease and music to create Harmony must
investigate Discord
you shall I question not find a way to
the Top If You diligently seek for it
for nature hath placed nothing so high
that it is Out Of Reach of industry and
Valor
[Music]
I am not afraid of an army of lions led
by a sheep
I am afraid of an army of sheep led by a
lion
no man never wedded clay and then left
it as if there would be Bricks by chance
and Fortune
he who is of a calm and happy nature
will hardly feel the pressure of age but
to him who is of an opposite disposition
euthan age are equally a burden
[Music]
I only wish that Ordinary People had an
unlimited capacity for doing harm
then they might have an unlimited power
for doing good
[Music]
the greatest way to live with honor in
this world is to be what we pretend to
be
the greater the difficulty the more the
glory and surrounding it
[Music]
all human actions have one or more of
these seven causes chance nature
compulsions habit reason passion desire
[Music]
youth is easily deceived because it is
quick to Hope
ideal man Bears the accidents of life
with dignity and Grace making the best
of circumstances
[Music]
the very spring and route of honesty and
virtue lie in good education
[Music]
worthless people live only to eat and
drink people of worth eat and drink only
to live
when men speak ill of thee live so as
nobody May believe them
[Music]
even when laws have been written down
they ought not always to remain
unaltered
there are two things a person should
never be angry at what they can help
and what they cannot
[Music]
apply yourself both now and in the next
life without effort you cannot be
prosperous though the land be good you
cannot have an abundant crop without
cultivation
[Music]
do not say little in many words but a
great deal in few
[Music]
when you want wisdom and insight as
badly as you want to breathe it is then
you shall have it
the One exclusive sign of thorough
knowledge is the power of teaching
[Music]
are you not ashamed of heaping up the
greatest amount of money and honor and
reputation and caring so little about
wisdom and truth and the greatest
Improvement of the Soul
[Music]
the learning and knowledge that we have
is at the most but little compared with
that of which we are ignorant
[Music]
one thing I know that I know nothing
this is the source of my wisdom
true wisdom comes to each of us when we
realize how little we understand about
life ourselves and the world around us
silence at the proper season is wisdom
and better than any speech
the only true wisdom is in knowing you
know nothing
I know that I am intelligent because I
know that I know nothing
[Music]
but his sister Artemis the wild the lady
of wild beasts scolded him bitterly and
spoke a word of revilement
you run from him Striker from afar fool
then why do you wear that bow which is
wind and nothing
they did not recognize her gods for
Mortals are hard to see
[Music]
her gray eyes clear the goddess Athena
answered down from the skies I come to
check your rage if only you will yield
seeing our Muse of the Rage of Achilles
son of Helios that brought countless
ills upon the achaeans
Beauty Terrible Beauty
a deathless goddess so she strikes our
eyes
hateful to me as the gates of Hades is
that man who hides one thing in his
heart and speaks another
once we'd left the island in our wake no
land at all in sight nothing but sea and
sky then Zeus the son of Cronus mounted
a Thunderhead above our Hollow ship and
the Deep went black beneath it
Athena you wish to be called righteous
rather than act right I say wrong must
not win by technicalities
[Music]
bear up my child bear up Zeus Who
overseas and directs all things is still
Mighty in the heaven
those who intend on becoming great
should love neither themselves nor their
own things but only what is just whether
it happens to be done by themselves or
others
true love never has a happy ending
because there is no ending to true love
[Music]
whatever possession we gain by our sword
cannot be sure of lasting let the love
gained by kindness and moderation is
certain and durable
[Music]
of all the varieties of Virtues
liberalism is the most beloved
[Music]
there are three classes of men
lovers of wisdom lovers of honor and
lovers of gain
one word frees us of all the weight and
pain of life
that word is love
[Music]
selfishness doesn't consist in a love of
yourself but in a big degree of such
love
[Music]
to love rightly is to love what is
orderly and beautiful in an educated and
disciplined way
love is the joy of The Good The Wonder
of the wise the amazement of the Gods
love is composed of a single soul
inhabiting two bodies
the touch of love everyone becomes a
poet
[Music]
foreign